hello guys my name is Chan Oh and today
we are going to be taking a look at my
Laden death 34 game so a lot of no 34
happened last weekend for those of you
who could not tune in to the live stream
I streamed pretty much the entire day I
did stream the entire develop an office
game that I made for Adam Day which is a
48 hour game programming competition in
which you have 48 hours to make a game
from scratch based on the theme which
gets released when the competition
starts so this time round a few things
happened first of all there were
actually two themes so the way that this
usually works is that a lot of people
can kind of vote for themes right
there's like these these rounds of theme
voting that happen before the
competition actually starts and usually
thousands of people vote for themes and
they essentially either like +1 0 or
minus 1 a particular theme right so they
kind of assign a score to them based on
how much they like the theme and then
move on to the next thing it's called
kind of well there are different there's
just voting and there's like theme theme
slaughter and all these different things
happen so that basically it's like the
theme that people hate less gets gets
chosen as the winner right so the
highest score so at this time there was
actually a tie between two themes right
and they were actually both negative
like they were like negative 160 or
something so no one really liked any
themes I guess overall the majority of
people just kind of felt a neutral I
guess about most themes or dislike them
but there were two themes which is the
first time that's ever happened I was to
my knowledge and so these two themes
work growth or growing sorry one of the
themes was growing and the other one was
to button controls right so I thought
you know let's kind of use both right
because like growing was a decent theme
but two button controls that's like one
of the themes that I like because that's
like a direct prompt for you to be like
your game has to have two button
controls and that's good because they
have to work around that brother right
I'm actually a big fan of kind of direct
themes so I decided to go with that
with yeah with two button controls and
and like as well as growing okay but two
button controls are kind of the base of
my game and I thought you know what
growing just makes me think of like
plants and nature and kind of natural
kind of processes right and so I thought
I just I want it I immediately came up
with the idea to have this plant kind of
grow upwards and I thought you know what
defines plant or like a vine even right
more than like a bunch of curves so I
set out to make this kind of curve
rendering engine and and I actually had
a like the in terms of technology and
whatnot I had an interesting change of
pace so as you know I asked you guys
what you want me to use and the winner
for that was unreal okay and I started
off using unreal for about an hour I
want to say and first of all I'd never
used unreal before and I know that
unreal is a very difficult tool to use
it's very difficult engine to use for
those of you who don't know how to use
it okay so I was like okay I could use
unreal I could learn how to use it
decently I guess and I could make a game
but then this idea that I had that I was
really like this is one of the few lot
of days where I actually had an idea and
I was like I'm gonna make this game I
like this idea I'm happy I'm happy with
it it's not too complicated I'm gonna
make this game in particular and I felt
so strongly about this idea and I'm like
this this like unreal just does not suit
this at all so I decided to I was
actually a live streaming of course and
I asked you guys if you wanted me that
like if it was if you want to be the
switch and use something that I was
comfortable with and you said yes so
basically I was I was thinking of doing
this in Java because I wanted to use
software rendering and I wanted to write
like my own little curved rendering
engine just for this and everyone said
yes like I actually did a straw poll and
I think 80% of people voted for that so
I ended up switching that maybe next
time I use unreal we'll see but I'm
always a big fan of using whatever
technology actually suits the idea more
anyway so I came up with this game it's
pretty simple you just have to get the
high score so when you grow your score
advances
destroy those kind of rocks that are in
your way your score increases by a
thousand and yeah it's just like kind of
an endless kind of runner I guess I'm
just trying yeah so the highest floor
I've seen so far has been I think 50,000
that I've actually witnessed friend of
mine at work
get that score and then I think someone
tweeted a score of like 60,000 to me or
something but anyway that's that's round
about the score that that's a pretty
good score and you won't see me get that
high and in this video but in the try
too hard I mean I didn't yeah
then sit there for an hour gathering
footage for this and but yeah see if you
can see if you guys can get it can get a
higher score and if you do tweet me I'm
over tweet it anyway so yeah the game
went pretty smoothly I pretty much
didn't work all of Saturday I think on
this game because I had stuff to do and
really I said I think I spent about 10
to 12 hours total on this the music for
this which I wrote which you can
download there'll be a link in the
description to a SoundCloud like track
which is the music for this that thing
down in time music from start to finish
took 40 minutes from me being coming up
I actually came up with the idea like I
was just sitting at my piano waiting for
my computer to boot and I came up with
the melody and whatnot straightaway and
it was just like it was just very very
smooth all very kind of fluent and the
development of this really happens
really quickly as I said the entire
thing done and like the entire game done
in like towns pretty much so I was
pretty happy with that I thought it was
pretty good game as you can see it's
vertical and maybe because of that I
might port it to mobile maybe I don't
know let me know if you're interested in
that maybe I'll do a bit of a series of
that or whatnot probably not but like I
might actually end up releasing it as a
mobile game why not
so let me know what you thought and
obviously polishing up the game but I
thought it went pretty well um I was
pretty happy with it and yeah I mean not
much else to say I hope you guys enjoy
it I might do like if you guys want me
to be like a code review or whatnot
leave a comment below leave a comment
below really with whatever you want to
see a link to play the game of course
will be in the description of this video
and that's it at like button if you
enjoyed the video and I'll see you guys
next time goodbye